Yo c’est Cyrus, et bienvenue, enfin, dans
ce nouvel épisode du Coup de Phil’ !
On va parler d’un sujet qui pour une fois,
et c’est pas pour me déplaire, s'ancre
entièrement dans notre société actuelle,
et va peut-être même changer votre vision des choses
On va parler du féminisme
de Simone de Beauvoir
Simone de Beauvoir c’est une philosophe du siècle dernier, et elle est très balèze
en remise en question. Par exemple elle
a reçu une éducation catholique et dès ses
14 ans elle remet en question sa foi. Elle
a aussi connu une histoire avec un philosophe
dont je vous ai déjà parlé, qui est Sartre, et
quand je dis histoire c’est une histoire
assez folle à base de notions bien à eux
: l’amour contingent et l’amour nécessaire,
et on parlera sûrement une autre fois mais
ça leur a permis entre autre d’être
poly-fidèles quoi !
Avec la méthode Sartre, toi aussi serre plein
de meufs, tout en gardant ta meuf. C’est
facile avec la méthode Sartre.
Beau gosse !
Avec la méthode de Beauvoir, toi aussi serre
plein de mecs, tout en gardant ton mec. C’est
facile avec la méthode de Beauvoir.
Ah la pute !
Avec cette scène on est en plein dans les
idées de De Beauvoir et de son livre le Deuxième
Sexe. Ce que nous dit de Beauvoir est plutôt
simple, en gros il y a une profonde inégalité
des sexes dans nos sociétés et “On ne
nait pas femme : on le devient.” Alors ironiquement
j’ai toujours vu ça dans ma tête lorsque
j’entendais cette citation :
Vous avez eu les félicitations du jury, je
vous remet votre diplôme de femme !
Oh ! Je suis une femme !
Pas du tout
Ce qu’il faut comprendre avec cette phrase c’est
que la société au sens large, donc la famille
la culture, et tout, t’apprends à être
une femme. Plus que “On ne nait pas femme : on le devient.” On pourrait presque dire
“On ne nait pas femme : on nous le fait
le devenir.” Et c’est par des procédés
tout bêtes. Par exemple on va pas avoir le même comportement face à
une jeune fille aventureuse
et un jeune garçon aventureux, ou
alors
face à un zizi de garçon ou un pubis de femme. Et d’une manière générale on va
donner un statut différent à la femme et
souvent on va la placer sous l’homme
Et pour de Beauvoir ça remonte à la nuit des temps, où les plus forts physiquement avait
le pouvoir.
Donc ça aurait été une toute autre histoire
si les femmes avaient toujours été comme
ça !
et pire, les hommes ont toujours tout fait pour le garder, ce pouvoir. Par exemple lorsque
les femmes savaient guérir c’était des
sorcières. Et du coup, il fallait les chasser et les brûler,
lorsque les mecs savaient guérir, c’était des médecins et pour être médecin, fallait
aller dans des écoles qui souvent ne laisser
pas entrer les femmes. Bref, ce genre de choses.
Et c’est la même chose du côté du travail ménager qui est un travail non valorisé
et non productif au sens économique du terme.
Voici des chiffres de l’Insee sur l’évolution
du travail ménager. En 24 ans les mecs en
font seulement 7 minutes de plus, donc si les
meufs en font plus d'une heure de moins c’est
clairement pas grâce à eux mais aux technologies
dans l’électro-ménager par exemple ou
aux femmes de ménages ! Femmes de ménages !
Hein ! Je pense que t'as saisi concept.
Putain ! Mais j’avoue c’est un truc de ouf.
En fait la société est dominée par des
hommes et construite par des hommes, donc
avec leurs point de vus,
leur règles sociales...
MAMAN, J'AI FAIM !
C’est chaud...
Là où c’est très interessant c’est
que ce “On ne nait pas femme, on le devient”
s’inscrit totalement dans l’existentialisme
de Sartre dont on avait parlé ici, le lien
est dans la description ! De la même manière que l’existence précède l’essence et
que nous sommes une page vierge et que nous allons nous définir par rapport à nos actions,
que nous ne sommes pas déterminés, que nous pourrons changer, et bien la femme aussi, elle nait comme
une page vierge et c’est à elle
de se définir. Donc c’est très intéressant
de voir cette influence là dans la pensée
de De Beauvoir.
Simone... Heu... J'ai fini ton livre.. T’as
un petit peu pompées mes idées, quand même ?
Non...
Bah si ! Quand même !
Putain, mais t’es grave toi ...
Quoi ?
Une femme peut pas avoir ses propres idées, du coup elle
a copié sur un homme, c’est ça ?
Mais non, mais pas du tout ...
Putain ! Mon propre mec quoi…Sérieux, putain...
Mais mon amour, tu sais bien que j’adore
quand tu me pompes !
Il y a donc des inégalités entre les hommes
et les femmes, et des attitudes
discriminatoires en raison du sexe. Et ça, ça a donné un mot relativement récent
forgé par les femmes qui combattent ces inégalités
par analogie avec le racisme : le sexisme.
Et c’est dans le but de combattre ces inégalités
qu’existe le féminisme. Et c’est quelque
chose qui dépasse les convictions politiques,
économiques, il y a plein de courants de
féminisme genre libéral, socialiste... Y'en a plein...
Et c'est pas renverser le système économique
actuel qui va instaurer une égalité homme - femme. C’est quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus profond et ancré
que ça.
ça c’est sûr !
Mais il y a une nuance qui est particulièrement
importante, et qui concerne les origines
des différences homme - femme. De Beauvoir
considérait que toutes ces différences et
discriminations, ou leur quasi totalité
étaient d’origines culturelles. Et du coup, les féministes
qui sont de cet avis aujourd’hui , elles sont dites
beauvoiriennes, ou constructivistes,
dans les sens ou la femme se construit. Et le courant
qui s’oppose à ça c’est celui qui considère
que malgré tout, il y a une différence d’essence
entre homme et femme, qui ne réside pas dans
le culturel, mais que c'est en rien une raison pour qu’il y ait inégalité
et discrimination. En gros “égaux dans
la différence”. C’est justement les différentialistes,
ou essentialistes.
Enfin ! Mais c'est évident que l'instinct maternel c'est quelque chose qui est inné, qui est dans nos gênes !
Mais n'importe quoi c'est quelque chose qui s'acquiert avec la société ! T’en penses quoi toi ?
Il fait un peu froid, je trouve ?
Donc depuis quelques décennies on a une émancipation de la femme. De Beauvoir s’exprime
aussi sur ce fait : pour elle la femme devient une femme libre, notamment sexuellement,
et donc elle se détache de cette image de chasteté qui était reliée à la mère ou à la sœur, et du coup, ben
un mec qui voit ça, il se dit : " ben, attends, si elle est libre sexuellement  pourquoi, elle coucherais
avec moi ?" Sauf que la liberté c’est justement l’inverse, c’est choisir à qui on offre son corps.
En tout cas, que vous soyez une femme ou un homme, n’hésitez
pas à vous abonnez pour ne rater aucune des prochaines vidéos et à  passer le coup de phil à un ami et faire péter la facture téléphonique.
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace ! Yallah
!
J’espère que son idéologie est maintenant
plus claire pour vous, et que vous
comprenez d’avantage les enjeux des féministes
et ce qui les poussent à agir et
à s’insurger.
Alors évidemment comme tout courant militant et actuel,
les noms des différents courants ne sont pas encrés
Ce qui compte c’est plus les idées qui sont derrière
les noms.
Alors après ce serait intéressant de faire
une vidéo pour voir ce que la science nous
dit là dessus, sur cette différence Homme
Femme, mais là c’est pas le sujet puisque
je ne vous parle pas de mes idées, ni de
celles de la science, on parle avant tout vous rapporter les propos de Simone de Beauvoir
Et j'espère que c'est réussi !
D'ailleurs je suis désolé pour l'absence de vidéo ces derniers temps
Je suis de nouveau là, je suis au taquet, et j'espère que vous aussi !